Speaker 1: Today, we are going to be speaking
to Bill Share, certainly a familiar face on
the show, although in a literal sense the
current hairstyle and beard makes him look
a little bit different than normal.
Bill Share is a contributor to the Washington
Monthly political magazine and Real Clear
Politics and also hosts the history podcast
When America Worked a Bill.
Always great to have you on.
Speaker 4: Do I still hold the record for
most David Pakman your appearances or have
I lost that?
Speaker 1: I think so.
There was a period where Richard Wolffe surpassed
you, but you've taken it back now, I think.
Which is good.
OK, so we've got the one six commission moving
forward, but that's not a Biden proposal.
Joe Biden has talked about he has this tax
reform plan.
He has a jobs plan.
He has an infrastructure plan.
There are different ideas for how different
elements would be paid for and disagreements
as to the size of packages and all of these
different things.
If you just look at the rest of this year.
Do any of those things get done, which is
the most likely which is the likely to benefit
Biden the most politically?
Speaker 4: Well, I think Biden has made clear
inaction is not an option in terms of infrastructure.
OK, I don't think he can go back to the voters
in twenty twenty two and said, sorry, I got
bumped.
Guess my fought really hard.
He needs something.
And what's interesting is what's happening
with the one six commission, which is very
bitter, partizan, fractious.
Yes.
You've got three or five House Republicans
that came over, but McCarthy was against that.
McConnell came out against it.
It seems like it's same old, same old, moving
farther and farther apart.
While that's happening, Biden continues to
meet with Republican leaders on infrastructure.
Right.
And Mitch McConnell, of all people, says,
I think we can do 600, 800 billion dollars
now.
Democrats aren't necessarily over the moon
about that, but it's hardly the same as I
want to make Joe Biden a one term president.
I'm not going to give him anything for it,
for anything.
There is.
And I understand people can be mistrustful
and cynical about McConnell's motives here.
I don't I'm not arguing that McConnell is
a saint or doing something out of the goodness
of his heart.
But clearly, there is something there that
he does not want to be seen as obstructionist
on infrastructure.
There is a worry on the Republicans part.
And the question is, can exploit that to get
a bill with 60 votes, which he may need to
get if he cannot get 50 for a partizan reconciliation
bill on infrastructure.
Speaker 1: Well, now so I guess I'm I'm I've
been thinking about whether the fear of appearing
obstructionist is warranted because, I mean,
just to think a little bit about the one point
nine trillion covid stimulus under Biden where
people got the fourteen hundred dollars, there
were two discussions when that was going on.
One, will the Democrats suffer if they pass
this without Republican support?
I think the answer is clearly no.
People got their fourteen hundred bucks and
they're pleased with that.
And some even believe that Republicans actually
had a role to play.
We just looked at a bunch of polling.
Many of the people who got the fourteen hundred
bucks don't know that they got it only because
of Democrats.
The other side of that was will Republicans
suffer in any way for having not participated
at all in a covered stimulus bill that was
quite popular with the American people.
It seems the answer there is also sort of
no, at least as far as I can tell right now.
So what I'm kind of getting to is if Democrats
just keep doing stuff on their own when they
can and the things that require 60 votes,
obviously they can't do that, is they're really
going to be any consequences for anybody,
for Democrats just doing stuff on their own.
Speaker 4: What what's an unknown here is
inflation.
Hmm, we don't know what the economy is going
to look like six months from now.
One month.
Now, one year from now, we have these we have
an inflationary spike in the past month, but
which the Biden people say is temporary.
The Fed thinks it's temporary.
The Fed thinks it can manage it.
It's not going to get its act to go off the
rails.
Speaker 1: Well, remember, I mean, it wasn't
from March to April.
It was April twenty one compared to April
20 where there was a complete demand collapse.
Everything was cheaper than ever.
I mean, I think it's quite possible that it's
an artifact, really.
Speaker 4: Well, there is.
I mean, there's also a month to month inflation
increase to.
Speaker 1: Oh, that one I haven't seen.
Speaker 4: The bigger spike is year to year.
Yeah, OK, OK.
But there is a March to April also.
Speaker 1: I hadn't seen
Speaker 4: it, but it could, it could just
be the weirdness of coming out of a pandemic
that will correct itself.
Yep.
Or not.
So I think both parties are kind of waiting
and watching to see who is going to get the
better of that argument down the road.
But having said that.
You know, you're not seeing Republicans say
we should not have any infrastructure bill
because we're in the midst of inflation, and
that would just make things worse.
That's a long term bill.
That's for eight to 10 years.
It's not about today.
And there are Republicans that still want
to bring home some bacon to their own states
and districts.
So.
And on top of that, I think I think it's safe
for as a fact.
I think McConnell wants to be able to say
he did something, he would like to obstruct
a lot of other things, but was able to say,
hey, look, I'm a reasonable guy.
I met them halfway on fiscal traditional infrastructure.
And that gives me the credibility to block
him on all these other things.
So if so, they are talking.
What the two parties are saying on infrastructure
have overlap.
The red lines are being drawn, do not negate
the possibility of a compromise.
And again, Biden can't come up with nothing.
No, Joe Manchin could say, OK, forget the
Republicans are not being reasonable here.
We tried.
You gave your best shot.
I'll go with you on reconciliation right now.
He is not there yet.
And we don't know if he's ever going to get
there.
So you may be right in saying, hey, Democrats
can do this politically without repercussion.
That's only true if 50 Senate Democrats agree
to do that.
Yeah, she doesn't agree or Kazimir doesn't
agree or what have you, then you just can't
do it.
And I think as long as Republicans are putting
semi reasonable proposals on the table, I
don't think of Joe Manchin pulls the plug
on the process that might require you to do
that kind of deal.
Speaker 1: One of the changes in the Republican
Party, certainly during the Trump era, but
in particular in the last four months, is
that while Mitch McConnell is going to meetings
and a few Republicans are going to meetings
to talk about things, the Republican Party
is not really a party of policy at this point
in time.
Some members of the House just straight up
say it.
I mean, Madison, Katharine's office has said
we're not we're not running a policy office.
We're running a communications office and
we're doing tweets and we're doing Meems.
And we're doing talking about guns on the
House floor, on his wheelchair and all of
this different stuff.
At some point, will that implode or can that
be viable when Republican voters don't seem
to mind the idea of just getting in the way
of Democrats and not really doing anything?
Speaker 4: Well, this is what both the Democratic
and Republican negotiators have to consider.
I mean, there's I think there you look at
the majority of the Republican Party, look
at polls, look at the House caucus, this and
you'd say this is a party still obsessed with
Trump cult of personality, not interested
in real legislating or governing, just want
to fight culture war battles and exploit grievances.
And how can you work with that?
But here you got Liz Cheney making the minority
point within the Republican Party.
We have to get back to being a party of substance
and policy we can't sustain as a cult of personality
party.
I'm not quoting verbatim here, but I think
that's the gist of what she's saying.
Well, yeah,
Speaker 1: but also, I mean, I have to say,
she voted with Trump like ninety three percent
of the time.
The policy she wants to get back to, I don't
know.
It's like I'm not sure that she's really that
different.
Speaker 4: Well, she Liz Cheney wants to get
back to hawkish foreign policy.
Yeah.
She wants the Republican Party to be a neocon
party again.
Yeah.
True.
That's her.
OK, now, do you have in the Senate enough
Republicans who take a longer view say, look,
we can't survive as a cult of personality
party?
That may be fine if you want to hold on to
two hundred House seats, but if you actually
want to be a majority, again, if you get the
presidency again, you want to have I said
the functions again that we have the upper
hand with, we have to look beyond the immediate
passions of our base and we have to show that
we can we can do it and survive doing it.
This is an opportunity for the Romneys and
the Portmans and the and the capital and perhaps
the McConnells to say we can still do this,
bring home stuff for our states and our districts
and people will respect this for it.
And so if that sentiment is there, can Biden,
can Schumer, can Manchin, can they draw that
out and come up with the bill that they can
get done?
Is 800 billion traditional infrastructure
without raising taxes on corporations are
not a lot of corporations, some pills, some
bitter pills for Democrats to swallow in that.
But still some go back to the public and say,
I did this tangible stuff that we did deliver
it for you.
Reward us in twenty twenty one, twenty two,
twenty four for it.
There is a potential for common ground there.
If both parties see short term slash long
term incentive for their own parties.
Speaker 1: There is I believe.
No chance that the capital gains rate gets
increased the way Joe Biden has signaled he
would want to do, I think it's just one of
those things that in the end isn't going to
happen.
It seems very exciting to a lot of people.
I think there's a very interesting budget
calculation in terms of what it would do.
It would be significant.
I see that as an example of something that
is just is destined to die and it's not happening.
Am I being unrealistic in my analysis of that
piece?
Speaker 4: Not necessarily.
Look, let me try to let me try to tie a few
threads together, if I may.
Yes.
So Biden has two big tax proposals connected
to the American jobs plan and the American
families plan, right.
The American jobs plan, which is mostly traditional
infrastructure, but goods gets a little nontraditional,
long term care, school construction, things
Republicans don't count as traditional.
That's tied to the corporate tax increases.
And Joe Manchin has said, I don't want to
go as far as you know, Joe Biden, I meet you
halfway there.
So you have some indication that BI doesn't
have 50 Democrats for his proposal, as is
Republicans saying we don't want to touch
the Trump tax cut at all.
All right.
We want to increase user fees, maybe increase
the gas tax, maybe maybe create a new vehicle
mileage tax, which would hit electric cars
and hybrid cars more.
Speaker 1: We don't want that.
Let's say.
I don't want that.
Speaker 4: Well, you know, it's not crazy.
I mean, we have functioned on a user pays
principle for highways for over 50 years.
It's not a new idea the Republicans have.
The only Newnes is extending it to hybrid
electric cars.
Right.
So, again, if you're Joe Biden and getting
a bill is first and foremost and you can't
get 50 for your ideal tax plan, that makes
the Republican plan more relevant in the discussion.
So Biden may say, you know what, I don't need
the corporate tax hike here now.
So let me add one other element here.
What's the other big thing that Biden really
needs?
He needs to extend that child tax credit expansion.
That is a signature policy achievement.
The monthly checks are going to start coming
in July, but they expire after December.
If they run out, you've not only lost your
signature policy achievement, people are going
to be mad.
Hey, you get these checks that you cut me
off and this might have to get decided during
an inflationary spike where people might say,
hey, but you put too much money in the system,
you're over it, you're overheating the economy.
The way you can argue you're not going to
overheat is with a paid for by not having
to be deficit spending, but having those checks
be offset with other tax revenue, which some
Democrats like Angus King, who's independent
but caucuses with Democrats have already said,
I want that paid for.
You're not going to get a hundred, so child
tax credit expansion, a hundred billion dollars
a year.
The corporate tax hike plan of Bohannon's
is one sixty six billion a year and the taxes
on the American families plan, which run wealthy
individuals, that's another hundred billion
dollars a year.
Right.
There's only so many pots of money here.
So if you need a hundred billion dollars a
year to cover the child tax credit expansion
to extend it beyond twenty, twenty one, that's
probably going to be a reconciliation bill.
You're trying to get Republicans to come along
and help save your partizan policy achievement.
So save your partizan tax proposal for that
and work with Republicans on something that's
not as partizan for the infrastructure bill.
I think that's where the stars are most likely
to align.
Speaker 1: The thing I really continue not
to understand about the corporate tax rate
discussion, and maybe this is by design and
this is exactly the theater that that they
want the corporate tax rate being twenty one,
twenty eight or thirty five.
It has a far smaller impact than a lot of
people believe.
First of all, because it doesn't apply to
sole proprietorships, it doesn't apply to
LLC, it doesn't apply to S corporations, all
of which are taxed as pass through entities
at the personal income tax rate.
So then you've got just the bucket of C corporations
and a few other specific entities that are
subject to the corporate tax rate.
But many of them are paying zero or nine or
eleven or seven percent anyway because of
the extensive deductions and a lack of a corporate
alternative minimum tax.
So I feel like it's a sort of insane asylum
discussion about Mansion thinks this and it
was thirty five and twenty eight when it's
not really the way that you capture tax revenue
from C corporations anyway unless you deal
with the other stuff.
Are both sides just agreeing to pretend that's
not an issue?
Speaker 4: Well, that's why it's relatively
easy for buy in to say, OK, Joe Manchin, I'll
cut to twenty eight to twenty five the corporate
income tax rate, because the bigger issue
are the loopholes.
Right.
I don't want to make sure they can't escape
paying the rate at all, but that's going to
be a very hard thing to negotiate.
Negotiate with Joe Manchin.
Some some middle ground there with the Joe
Manchin may not be exactly what Biden has
right now, but you can get something from
him.
Much, much harder to get that with Republicans.
Yeah.
So why try.
Why kill yourself to get 60 votes on the corporate
tax reform, which would probably be very,
very difficult to be very, very watered down
when you need some big money for the child
tax credit expansion.
So that's why I think, again, I can't promise
this is what's going to happen.
Maybe they go full partizan across the board.
Maybe they shoot the moon completely because
Republicans are, too are too obstructionist.
I mean, I can't negate that possibility.
But so long as Republicans are in the game
at the those matches keeping them in the game,
I think you've got to keep in mind that you
got to have a paper in your back pocket by
the end of the year, especially if inflation
is spiking and you got to show that you're
paying for your checks.
Speaker 1: A lot to look forward to, I think
is the point.
And certainly as we get into twenty twenty
two things that I mean, the child tax credit
may play significantly in the twenty, twenty
two midterms.
So these are not merely academic discussions,
I think is fair to say.
We've been speaking with Bill Share, contributor
to The Washington Monthly, Politico magazine
and Real Clear Politics and of course, host
of the history podcast, When America Worked.
Bill, always great having you on.
Speaker 4: My pleasure to talk to you soon